再聊一聊 对 但就是给大家聊一聊嘛比如说第一个就是当时你为什么我可能做前端嘛对 我们有很多其实技术的方向其实我还挺那个 算是 咋说呢一个是我大学的时候其实就已经开始在那个写一些代码写一些那个c shop然后当时变完了之后也是说我自己做了一个判断我觉得c shop可能
会比较难找工作都是我个人的情话就不代表真的是这样子只是我自己感受啊所以不要担心就anyway我当时会判断说可能是效果在国内可能比较难找然后应用的范围不是特别广然后我想来想去觉得如果继续走后端可能不是我特别感兴趣我可能会更喜欢这种我特别酷炫
一个页面效果特别酷炫然后可以做很多肯消负的事情的这种这种这种东西我个人会更感兴趣一点所以就就就做前段我是一三年一三年毕业之后就全职做前段然后到现在反正也没有也没有跳过就一直都在做这件事情我自己感受下来其实前几天也发了一一一篇文章就我自己感受下来会觉得
这个方向还是挺ok的至少对我来说我觉得都还没有到电话版而且离得很远然后会觉得还是挺好的对 大概是这样子吧ok那我去想问一下就是比如像你现在比如在直播间的同学看来就你已经是比如说阅读了这么多原码就已经其实很深入很深入底层了嘛那比如说你觉得在未来的一些其他的方向上面比如说你还有很大的
比如你觉得这个天花板可能很高嘛那你觉得比如在哪些领域其实还是能继续去在更深入或者说很多现在啊现在你说服务端它复杂吗确实很复杂但是前端有前端的自己的那种那种复杂度的领域比如说那个什么啊一代吧一代吧就是一件无论前后端都很复杂的一件事情就是你要做一个拖拉转然后生成页面这件事情还挺简单的
问题是你要生成之后的这些页面它要足够的好足够的快足够的易用然后以及能满足一系列的业务场景如果要做到这个程度其实是很难很难的然后难的事情然后并且有一定的商业价值的事情我就会觉得是值得去看值得去投入的一个方向再其次再其次就是包括那个可实化
我们都可以看到3s或者其他的一线一线三D款件可以搭出来特别酷炫特别好的
包括在前端里面做很多复杂的交互游戏之类的这样的效果那这件事情其实就很少人就先对来说比较少人在研究他有强的市场需求但是他也有比较高的一个门槛所以懂这一块的人还挺少的如果会这一块就也是职业上比较有链点的我觉得挺值得去投入的一个方向再其次是工程化工程化的话我刚才也说了很多公司特别是大公司都需要这种做基建的团队
字节里面就有挺多的然后对啊这一类的也是很容易就是比较比较比较深度比较深然后容易去拿结果的一个一个领域等等的就如果你要去分的话现在你单纯去做一个业务项目可能会会觉得还挺简单的但是如果你去深挖这一些我们觉得还遥不可及的方向的话就是你的未来能走的
這個長度這個職業路徑可能會更好一點更慘一點我是這麼覺得然後我自己現在就投入在低代碼因為低代碼的這種產品其實也見過挺多了還是比較期待到時候就是你說的這個東西比如說你們做好這個發布到時候我要體驗一下OK剛才講這個其實有點大了就是因為尤其是可能對你自己來說或者說
对你跟你差不多阶段的同学可能会比较意义所以我觉得第二个问题可能会更对于直播间很多同学会更加有价值一些就是比如说你也是从新罗开发者走过来的嘛那在这个过程中你经验的一些成长阶段我觉得可能有一些东西是现在的直播间的同学能参考我为了你这个问题专门写了一篇文章我知道就那篇文章
我自己总结是这么几个阶段一个是我干脆我啥都不懂然后但是也没有权质的去做过前端会的东西就值得负责但是我是一三年那会那会的整个就业行情还是比较好的比较容易就算我只会负责只会拼一些简单的HTML我还是能找到一份工作虽然是小公司但是至少
能有一个真实的让我去做真实项目的一个锻炼的机会然后这个阶段我进去之后其实也没太多人带anyway这个不重要重要的是我会发现我现在的能力可能一开始并不胜任并不能做到公司要求我做的一些事情那我就会去学那我学完之后会发现这是升任阶段就是说我第一阶段是要能让自己的能力达到公司的要求
达到公司的要求之后这只是最基础的非常非常基础的一个阶段再往后那公司的所现在所用的技术所所所所做的这些东西所设计的这些技术方案就完美了吗不一定很多时候都很多项目都会有优化的空间那优化的空间可能是你工程效率开发效率然后业务性能等等很多方向
可以去无法觉得就会发现说如果你真的用心去去看的话其实多多少少还是会有一些可以优化的东西然后我当时就是我为什么要写这么低效的代码为什么要重复自己为什么要用这块而已然后就不断的去看为什么要写CSS然后去用了那个lessSARS然后等等等等反正一堆的乱七八糟工具就是当时突破了
在盛任的基础上突破了公司的现有的房间去找到新的解决方案然后有了新的解决方案之后呢其实在往下就是我可能能做某一件事情能把它做好甚至能稍微的比别人预期的高一丢丢好一丢丢那我能不能再好一点点呢
这个时候再往下就可能是进入到某一个垂直领域就是某一个技术的垂直领域的一个深水渠那可能我就开始要去看原代码那就是你如果真的要继续往下深入你要优化性能问题你要做出一些体校的工具你可能就得理解它底层的实现原理那这个时候就是单个体系的单个技术站的深入的一个理解然后OK到了这一个阶段之后你基本上可以算是一个
比较高级比较有经验的同学那再往后可能就是给你一个业务方向比较复杂业务方向那你能把这个方向卡过住你能不单单是单个锤子的技术领域而是综合的包括前端包括后端包括很多东西乱七八糟的反正都有一个比较好的比较深入的理解然后能根据你的业务形态业务需求和团队的状态去设计出一些比较合适的
工程化的体系或者是技术的方案或者是技术的架构等等这就是又到下一个阶段这个阶段你开始可以带人就能辐射自己的影响力你不再是一个自己做好就行而是带着一群人能去一起冲的一个阶段然后再往后的话可能就是再跨越是一个指门
再跨越你的前端这一个职能的限制再往前是那个可能带着其他职能去创造性的去做一些事情而这样一个阶段对那总结下来说白了就是一个是胜任胜任的基础上去突破突破的基础上去生化是去深入体系化然后再往后就是能
能带人的一个阶段然后再往后就能带更多人去解决一个更大的一个问题的一个阶段ok吹水是这么吹的对我觉得大家可以去看一下那个文杰写的那些文章当然我们后面总结的时候我们也会把那些文章带然后对然后大家直播间里面就因为我们现在既是我们的这个访谈环节吧大家如果在过程中有什么想跟
就是文杰这边聊一聊的大家可以在直播间提问然后我们会根据情况去选择问题跟在跟那个文杰探讨一下那我们今天讲一下第三个我们想聊的问题啊今天第三个想聊的话题这是一个可能在前端非常热的一个话题就是这个view和react这两个流派之间的一些battle吧对我想看看文杰是怎么看这个事情
ok 其实前面我也说了就这两个东西有代码我也看过然后也基本上用过但是我个人呢我会更喜欢view为什么呢因为它上手成本更低如果我现在要去搭一个团队我会有钱选择view因为我培训的成本会更低就我可能我其实我自己都会一直都会有这种所谓的培训的习惯就我新同学进到我们团队我都会帮他看一下
为了让你适应这个环境你需要学习一些什么东西然后如果我帮很多人做过这种学习的计划然后就会发现说你如果是reactor跟view的差异还是挺大的view里面你需要掌握的东西一些原理的东西还是相对比较简单容易理解容易上手而且他在期待码的时候更加直观一点但是reactor他可能会天花板更高就是他能做到的这种性能的体验或者开发的体验可能会更好
但是他下线也会更低就是你很容易犯错你对新人来说很容易就会出现一些问题这是我自己的观点所以我会更推荐我自己会觉得如果我要去重新开始创建一个团队我会优先用这个view或者是有机会的话我也可以去试一下现在比较新的一些其他的包括有一个叫Stayley
是叫Static或者是另外一个我突然想不起名字了就反正也都挺新的一层MVM的框架我都会想去试一下但是反正我对Reactor不是特别有好感这是我个人的问题大家不要攻击我就这样吧没关系等我们路播发播一定会被攻击的
但我觉得这个没关系我觉得只是一个个人选择和倾向的问题他其实没有说到底谁好谁一定好的谁好谁坏这个倒不是这样的OK然后另外讲一个点就刚才直播间有同学问问题啊就是说就是他讲到一个Vite和WebpackVIT是ViteVite对Vite他会后面会替代Webpack吗他问了这样的一个问题我觉得
首先我没有这资格去做这个判断就是这个行业大佬们的事情其实的话几次的话就我的经验来说我觉得很难因为因为再怎么样有一个有一个常委效应你说的替代如果是百分百替代的话基本上不太可能对吧有意义很难包括现在我们都还有人在用的IE你说可能我们能代替IE吗那现在还是有人在用IE啊就这个逻辑就
台幹的話是這個邏輯其次的話正經一點回答就是那個我覺得也不太可能原因就在於說可能微派他本身也在發展微派他現在也有一些這種一步模塊就一步編譯延遲編譯的能力他延遲編譯完了之後的那個性能效果其實還挺好的甚至可以我沒有具體去測過我簡單測了一下體驗特別好
包括wifi他现在也有这种像那个网纯之类就是我想表达就是他本身也在存在本身他自己也看到了很多问题所以他自己必然是在不断地迭代虽然他的代码还是比较乱比较难懂但是他还是有存在空间的然后呢其次的话是前面也调过有一些场景可能据我所知啊就是
包括小程序包括那个桌面端应用包括一些更复杂的一些系统可能会用WiPad比较多因为WiPad已经是相对比较成熟了然后Vit它本来就不是想要跟WiPad竞争了它对比较的不是WiPad然后Vit它底层基于Lowup然后还有YesBuild之类的Anyway就是我觉得有一些产品下无论是现在还是未来可能
vite还是挺长的路要走但是我觉得现在去学是很值得的因为我们未来的一个可能的出现的产品是你有一些项目是用vite去写另外一些项目是因为vip去写我觉得这种情况会更加的可能性会更高就好像我们现在有一些项目是用view写有一些是用reactors类似的概念
对所以我觉得都学一下呗好卷啊而且我觉得文杰你真的是很官方滴水不漏啊这个问题回答我怕被说没有任何问题这个太滴水不漏好的好的然后啊这个这个直播间刚有两个问题啊就一个是说现在面试react多然后有一个讲说问题大了现在用哪个那刚才你讲过了吗其实就是你本身react和view都在用
对吧然后就不用回答了我其实也可以补充两句就是react和面试的问题我自己是这么理解的如果我平常在面试的时候如果我面的候选人他更擅长用view他简历里面出现view的频率更高我会测重用view的问题如果他测重于react我会问react的问题
如果他两个东西同时出现并且就都挺多的OK那两个都问就我想表达的意思就是并并没有说就可能很多比较成熟的面试官或者比较有经验的面试官并不会只问他懂的而是会就着你的情况去问你懂的你擅长的是view专注的是view的话我当然是要问view的东西我问react的话那本资上就不想你来的
我懂你的意思我觉得下次如果那个人又有view和viewed的话你可以问一下我们今天这三个问题可以好的我们这个问题先往下吧我觉得有一个问题是比较贴切我们的问题确实都是针对文姐做过一些进行设计的因为像文姐刚才讲到她写过那么多的文章
其实我觉得有个问题就是想问一下因为其实写文章这个过程一方面是沉淀嘛然后能总结过往的一些自己的一些经验然后在这个过程中其实也能提升自己所以想了解一下就是文杰是怎么去提高自己这个写作和分享这个技巧的嗯OK又得光放一下就是其实说白了我身边的同学应该就是跟我认识的现实里面认识我的同学应该都知道都能感受到我是一个特别焦虑的人就是特别容易焦虑
然后所以呢就老是害怕被裁员就anyway就有这种危机感一直都有这种危机感然后在这危机感的情况下我就得想办法去做一些改变那我就会有一个很强的目的性就是想要有一个就很强的目标就想要能做得更好一点就是在自己现在的基础上在工作之外去挖掘一些更多的能力
就anyway就是克服这个说白了目标就克服这个焦虑感我去做这件事情的时候我会觉得比较舒坦就相对来说就如果让我去看电视我现在的状态就是如果让我看电视我会很难受就因为我会很焦虑这如作真章反正已经很真正习惯了不是反而赛这个不是很好的习惯我不建议然后其次的话是
其实的话是那个有了一个特别强的目标感之后我觉得这个很重要你有了一个目标感之后你要去做的事情你才会比较容易坚持下去那有另外一个话题就是坚持怎么坚持呢一个是你有明确的知道我就是一定要做这件事情我不做的话我可能就活不下去了那OKOK那就一定要做有了有了一个明确目标然后再路径路径倒退回来不要给自己设定一些特别难特别
就特别复杂根本不可能达到的一个目标这就有一个目标管理还有路径拆解的就其实我在很多场合都说过你有一个明确的目标可执行的可达到的然后回个头来倒退你的里程碑你第一步应该做到什么状态第二步怎么什么状态然后OK这些都是事后去了的觉真OK还有另外还有一个技巧就是你要再不断的给自己一个正向的激励正向的反馈
让你自己觉得这件事情挺有意识的容易坚持下去就好像我来参加这直播间我其实是第一次来B站虽然这平台发了很多平台我第一次在B站我平台刷B站然后我现在自己在B站上聊天我觉得还挺开心的然后这是目标上其次的话就是翻诗方法我觉得就没有其他的方法就多写多练现在去翻译一下我之前写的文章我自己都看不下去
就很正常因为我就是写代码的我没有人天生会去写文章的主配是天才所以在之前的写了一型东西都是乱七八糟的没有重点没有结构但是练着练着聊着聊着写着写着可能就会有一些感觉对然后试试的可以补充一些写作的技巧我当时
说实话有一部分原因就是因为为了链子的写作的技巧而却专门写了决定小册但是我自己找的那个小便然后小便他告诉我可以提供这一些协助然后我一看他可以给我一些写作上的指导写作上的一些建议之类的OK那就来吧搞起然后确实这过程也学到了很多对所以总结下来就我觉得一个是要有明确的目标
第二个是要有可执行的路径第三个是要有在执行的过程中给自于一些正向的激励最终多写然后偶尔去看一些一些技巧发射方法我觉得就差不多了嗯可以可以太好了我跟你说今天我跟你讲这个EVA访谈是我最轻松的时候因为之前我可能都需要做一些总结啊然后你
你每次讲完就会把总结讲掉我就不用再讲总结了太开心了然后我看直播间里面有很多同学在讲就是你是卷王嘛所以我想聊下一个问题啊就是行业内卷的问题对于你这个卷王来说你是怎么样去打破这样的一个僵局了我其实我自己都没打破这个我就是这样子的这件事情就是首先是
我觉得可以自己跟自己就是大家可以自己跟自己去内心去聊一下吧就跟自己你真的需要去做这件事情吗就这世界很大然后除了技术之外还有非常多事情可以做如果一个反越很选那如果你特别不喜欢那我觉得可能你要问一下自己你真的适合或者是真的只有这个选择吗我觉得这个是挺重要的很多人是挺瞒目然后如果他
anyway这是我自有观点啊不要不攻击我就盲目入了汗然后然后很盲目的被推着走我真的见到很多人是在被推的了公司需要什么需要他做什么人告诉他他该干嘛然后他就去做了但是没有自己有思考没有自己有想法这挺可怕的就到你30岁像我这种年纪的时候就会觉得这种专来可能不太行那越找觉醒越找去反思是不是真的要
这么做这条路是不是真确的我觉得会越早越好了如果ok 最终你判定下来这件事情对你来说你可以做下去那又是另外一件事情那就是我可以提供一个建议就是核心竞争力有很多人啥都想要学一下看到什么都想要去看一下这是一个好习惯也是一个坏习惯好就好在他可能对如果你是一个高级的同学他能给你一个足够的广度足够的见识
支持技术的事业这好事但是坏事就坏习惯就在如果你本身没有自己特别强的那种技术层电没有自己对技术的理解没有对复杂事物的判断没有足够的学习能力那你可能会变成很分散三天打云两天晒网今天看一下这个明天看一下那个啥都看一下最终啥都不懂啥都没有一个深度就没有那种特别深的东西
这个情况也挺可怕的所以我给出来的建议就是先想办法去贵建自己的核心技能力然后做一些复杂的事情像我这样就是去把Wi-Fi全部看一遍前面也教了大家怎么看可以沿着这思路去看把复杂的东西做一遍有足够的自信足够的这种判断力之后你再去分散了去看这是OK的所以这就是一个购建自己的核心技能力
如果你有的自由核心技能力求你还挺有竞争试探的你在试探上还是挺有竞能力的我们不讨论特殊case最近发生了一件特殊case但是我们就不讨论了Anyway就是如果你有足够的核心技能力我觉得是能一定程度上不用太去那个啥的我们明白但是要保证核心技能力就得卷嘛先不说内卷的问题
你不说内卷吗捡还是要捡一定要付出更多的土地我觉得我今天这个问题真的设计的还是很理想的刚刚就有同学在问说九九又如何提升自己我忍不住想问这个问题你的工作强度是应该是很高的包括刚才有同学说你这个黑眼圈这么严重对吧那你怎么样在这样的一个因为这个问题我说实话问题有很多人会问这个问题
就是在高强度下怎么去保持这个技术那种输出当然因为我们之前有很多讲师他其实没有那么卷有的讲师其实还相当比较轻松的所以我觉得你应该是特别适合回答这个问题我喝高水OK没问题我刚才也说了我不是内卷或者为了卷而卷我就单纯的我会做别的事情我会如做真章我会很难受这是一个
就是这种我这种小正青年从小被父母对吧鸡娃鸡刀大的然后一种骗人的一种心理状态吧就不太健康我不太建议其次如果是呃如果是这个问题的话996我其实我工作以来一直的状态差不多都是这个状态然后我是怎么做的呢首先第一个问题是你现在做的事情真的是必须要去做的就是
我会有一个意识就是包括现在工作很忙我都会遇到一件事情的时候我第一反应是这件事情真的是我必须要去做的只有我能解决的问题如果不是那就把它分出去给合适的人去做比如说比如说别人问我一个什么技术问题我可能根本打不散那我就给他转到另外一个同学或者是别人让我处理一件什么瑣事那我为什么非得是完了我转到另外一个同学去做
就是一個合理的一個效率的提升的一種技巧吧就並不是所有問題首先並不是所有問題都必須被解決其次是並不是所有問題都必須你來解決如果你把這些亂七八糟的東西可以分散掉可以負載均衡調那你會發現你要做的事情可能會相對少一點那你在996之餘就有一些時間留給自己思考ok 這些思考時間
就挺重要的你可以在996的前以下去想一下现在团队遇到的什么问题这个问题是不是足够痛然后并且有足够的技术深度需要花一定的时间挺长的时间然后做技术优化才能解决ok 那你如果是到了这个程度有收益然后也有一定的复杂度那你就应该主动地去做你在做的这个过程一方面你解决的工作问题
另一方面是你自己也在成绩你自己也在也在也在增长当然了最后你能输出一些成果比如说开源的一些工具或者是一些文章博客之类的那会更好对对这是工作内的然后工作之外前面之前我太举行里面也分享过然后我就是我其实时间管理大事啊就是我会用很多的
这种业余时间来集中做学习集中写一些东西之类的比如说我每天回到家大概10点半然后我之后遛完狗之后就所有时间就铺在这上面了然后一直到睡觉或者是有时候很变态的就是被吹得急了就之前在写小册的时候被吹得急了就在地铁上面一边做地铁一边写小册这是真的没办法被吹急了
现在没有现在没有然后以及以及一些作末之类的我求也不太会去做别的事情就比较单约就是在学东西在看东西就大概是这样一个状态了就anyway总结一下就是你在我觉得就是首先要有一个前目标吧如果你上天打一个脸台上网就真的价值不到还不如不努力然后其次的话是
在工作内你就是想办法去解决团队里面遇到的问题团队里面现在灭灭的问题然后工作之外就节省就尽可能的把时间省下来去做可能在你未来三年一句鸡汤啊我当时就被说这句鸡汤骗到的在你未来三年五年还能有还有收益的一些事情对OK 从的就这样太到位了我觉得真的我觉得你应该是把时间管理已经做到极致了
刚才你现在讲那个点数10点回到家你还要写东西写到睡觉我心里想10点我已经睡觉了10点我可能已经睡着了可以可以可以我觉得这个就是我们为什么我没有技术出出内容出出的能力的原因了所以你在搞这个你是这个老板这个这个这个提沙龙老大哥没有没有
确实我觉得你刚讲那个问题我觉得挺啊就是这个问题是不是一定要解决是不是要一定要我去解决我觉得这个还蛮蛮我其实蛮认同的因为其实我之前有就是我待团队的时候话我经常会跟下面的就是我一线的听力的会讲一个点就是我这些上次我觉得在早要聊的时候我还做过分享我说懒人管理法则吗我说懒人管理法则就是不需要我不是我做的事情我一定不要做就尽量能偷懒就偷懒
当然这个拓胆是个引号,不是说什么也不做。是的,对。OK,那确实世界怪大是罗芝祥。你一说,直播间的视频是罗芝祥穿起来,罗芝祥的眼圈好像也挺黑的。我没有做这么幸运。OK,我不讲这个,我们继续往下吧。那个人不够,我觉得应该讲差不多了,我觉得可能接下来讲一下大家可能比较关键的一个公司层面的事情,就比如说
像字节是怎么去建设前端的一个记录氛围因为我知道字节最近也在做对外做很多前端内容的一些输出想了解一下这块是怎么去建设的大的背景除了还挺多的包括无数的公众号包括拜的FE顺便提一下我也是拜的FE的一个编辑之一每个每周都会办到文法周报然后对然后好几次的话就是
一个是各种功耗号然后还有各种的直播字节里面有一个技术学院是整个工资层面的一些一些一些技术分析然后等等等等这是大的层面我觉得大的层面很多工资做的球都差不多我要不要聊一下我们小团队层面没问题就是小团我觉得小团队层面对我来说是更可控的就在在之前我反正对我来说
说结果吧过程就不说过程过程说太多容易出问题就直接说结果吧首先是每周都会有技术分享然后并且这种技术分享并不是很水的而是真的我会我之前会一篇一篇的去盯去看这东西是不是有足够的深度然后呢再往前推为什么会有这个技术分享每一个人写的这东西是怎么写出来的
那再往前推就是我会用目标管理的方式吧跟大家同步说我希望你这个双月去输出这方面的一些什么什么的有生成次的文章当然那输出文章不是目标目标是你确实在现在这阶段你现在的整个职业的能力综合起来看可能这方面在你未来这个双月里面可能是值得你去学习的那其实就是一个定学习目标定完之后
这种技术分享 技术文章作为一个最终的输出结果验证的方式对 然后这过程其实执行下来还挺不错的然后再往前推 还有一个阶段就是可能会跟一些组队吧就是类似于A谁跟谁可能现在能力差不多或者某一个人可能比另外一个人强一点但就anyway就很适合配对
一起在工作之余去学习我会把这个学习作为一个虽然不是工作任务没有那么重但是也会很强调的一个东西然后在团队里面去逛圈然后所以时不时的会组织连连配对谁跟谁配组织队一起去学一起去输出类似于这样子然后所以在我们团队的整体的学习氛围还挺好的最开始要费挺多心思后面大家眼神习惯之后吃
每个人都差不多说我现在该学什么有一个基本的意识然后他愿意的话可以去时不时的去输出然后最终整个团队一直其实都在成长效果还挺好的我突然感觉你算讲的话挺轻松到我觉得过程应该我大概能感受到在这么高强度的下面可能还要学习应该是
我突然覺得我太仁慈了我突然覺得我是一個很仁慈了我當時是覺得這也可以成為一種比較好的一個管理手段為什麼因為我曾經的工作裡面面臨過遇到過不少這樣的場景就是某位小同學他做得還挺好的很多東西都很熟但是他進入了一個舒適區然後沒多久他就想走因為他覺得他自己沒有成長
嗯对这个很致命那在这种情况下这种我我自己涉嫌这种方式是能一定整路上带来一些新的书问然后至于他学的这些东西还可以给团队本身的技术还有一些一些一些问题能带来一些新的解决方法合乐而不稳嗯对我明白我理解可以这个嗯这个我今天学习了哈哈哈啊ok好的那我
我们到下一个问题比如说刚才讲的就是可能你没在招人嘛虽然是外包但我觉得你们对候选人一定是有一些要求的比如说你们会比较看着候选人什么样的一些品质不讲 包括技术方面我觉得分两个直接到一个是入职之前就面试过程面试的时候我能力有限我看不出太多这个人的一些性格的上的缺点之类我就只能说
你现在所表现出来的表达能力沟通能力你是不是明确地知道我说的问题并且明确地给出正确的或者是理解了这问题不一定能给出正确的答案但是至少你理解了我这问题并且你说的这些东西都是有条理的有结构的然后我能听得懂的如果你说得特别傻然后我就会觉得可能沟通表达上都会有点问题那可能就会比较深重然后其次的话
就包括你性格本身比如说你确实有一些人面试的过程中就你不问他就不会答然后他答也是是的没错就特别简短就特别懵糊涂就这种你说如果另外一个性格比较开朗就也不叫开朗吧就相对来说比较好沟通的同学的话
就是它的语言组织系统能力有语言组织能力和逻辑组织能力对对对这一代有东西这是入职之前大概就这样然后入职之后可能就会更更看重一个很关键的能力就是你能不能超出预期什么叫超出预期呢就是你可能是就我前面说的你干净来你可能只是要解决生人力问题但是我见过不少同学一旦满足了
工作需求解决了这个生润力问题之后它就停下来它就没有再往上去突破再去再往前走一步那其实我觉得这一块对我来说我会很看重不代表自己但是我自己在会特别看重这一块就是可能我给你一件事情我给你那个把目标背景全部同步好了之后你真的只是把这件事情就做到了80分
60分那我可能觉得还挺好的但是也就这样了但是如果你们更进一步做到80分90分更好那我会觉得这过程的时候要负责很多你得主动去想主动去理解主动去看很多东西然后你才能做得更好但是你做完这件事情之后你自己能力也有提升然后你在整个团队的引潜力也有提升说白了就是突破自往找到一个
更好的能提供一个更好的工作结果的这种能力我觉得是特别重要对然后当然了还有别的就包括什么沟通能力就前面说了人际交往的能力也确实有挺多程序员不太上场人际交往的我一直觉得人在事前你要做一件很复杂的事情的时候你面对的不再是一个单一的技术团队的时候你可能要
跟很多人共同这时候跟人打交道的能力可能会比写代码能力重要的多得多不过这就比较复杂了比较后面 直接剩下的后面了理解因为确实就是我们讲技术能力是基础嘛这个东西就像那个你少一块都不行这个是硬的东西但是软的一些方面的话可能
就是对职业生涯后期来说你的软实际可能会决定你职业生涯后期的一个就是往更高方层面走的一些东西这个也是但也是在我们行业里面吧我理解因为我们现在这个行业就是分工越来越细了然后你需要涉及的协作场景越来越多所以可能才会说把这个沟通这块看来比较重要如果你是一个比如说你是个独立开发者那你可能不一定是需要就不一定说这个东西很重要
你自己一个人全部搞定了不过反正anyway我觉得就算是生活里面会聊天的人比较散弹沟通的人还是先对来说比较容易吃鲜吧个人认为这个你确实因为本身我们这个话题有点太大了可能不是我们是我们也可以继续聊的
我们可以吃个饭聊ok对对对可以后续我们自己再聊一点好的那我们就回到今天的最后一个问题吧等一环扣一环刚才我要解释一下就是刚才有直播间有同学讲到说这个卷其实不是一个好的词但是我觉得在我们今天这个话题里面这个卷它是一个正向的它不是一个互相的因为我觉得内卷它可能是个互相的但是我觉得卷这个东西是正向的所以其实就是努力嘛在我们今天这个直播间里它的含义
是的那就讲一讲呗比如说文静你觉得接下来个人方面有没有一些什么样的规划我经常辅导别人你面试的时候你要怎么讲自己的个人规划但是我自己求不太上场讲这个问题今天讲不是面试okok其次的话是工作上我觉得还挺多事情想要去做的就但是细节不太不太适合
公開但是我是確實看到現在業務裡面現在工作裡面的一些很大的問題甚至對整個業務節奏都會現在以及未來都會產生一個比較大的影響然後這個問題剛好是我挺擅長的一個領域所以我想要把它做好然後也是努力了一段時間現在也正在努力然後WIP然後其次的話是這個工作上
然后其次的话是我的那个也想要去持续的去做一些社区的输出因为我觉得这件事情还挺有价值的因为他会倒逼我去看挺多东西然后去思考之类的所以我会坚持去做吧然后可能不会绝不会把它做得太重但是讲到说就是继续写点东西然后因为偶尔直播一下就差不多然后
对对对然后这是对我来说算是第二的第二职业曲线就一个另外一条成员的路线然后在其次的话是其实站完站完下有一些东西也不太方便讲有一些很具体的东西也不太方便讲说白了就是继续升职涨心然后组建一个一个好业更好的
继续让团队更强更类似的明白好吧这边因为你说继续细节方面不太适合这个对行吧这个问题其实有点或者或者换一个角度讲就是具体的这种规划我觉得有挺的东西是不太适合公开的但是有一些经济的逻辑或者通用的套路比如说你得有一个
职业上的目标然后比如说就我刚刚说的升职加薪那为了达到这个目标你需要做什么事情之类就是一个目标还有目标倒退目标拆解离神碑设定然后目标管理还有路径执行一堆的问题对 anyway 就要有一个目标又上升到方法论了有的话总好过没有吧对方法论还是很有必要的
因为很多东西就是很多说是这样的就我们可能我觉得很多时候我们在做些事情的时候就有的人他可能你会发现有的人做事情他比较顺但他不一定能给你明确的讲出方法论来但你要是比如说真的把方法论放在面前就会发现他其实很多行为跟那个方法论是很接近的是的对所以其实如果你提早知道了一些明确的方法论的时候你再去做一些事情在里面能代入的时候其实是很有帮助的可能会让你做事情会快很多
很多人是摸索出来的很多人可能是在这个做的过程中碰到一些逼呀或者说有一些经验他慢慢的去形成了这个他自己的这套或者说他去接近了这个方法了但这个过程其实是蛮痛苦的这个问题其实聊得有点意犹未尽因为其实我本来想从你这本聊要再更多细细但你都说不方便讲的就没办法了本来还想要你的这个规划
没问题没问题我觉得是这样等你这个项目真的OK了我觉得后续我们给他讲一下对肯定有机会的因为我们也一直在做嘛行吧那今天时间上我觉得也不早了今天确实还聊了挺多的包括本来主题分享就时间比较长然后聊这些话题过程还比较有意思我觉得直播间大家对这个些问题也觉得蛮好的那我觉得这个我们的目的就达到了